imagínense que tengo dos problemas
mundiales en mis manos por este lado
tengo todos aquellos problemas
ambientales cambio climático
deforestación es masivas y todo tipo de
contaminación y en esta otra mano tengo
todos los problemas sociales incluyendo
depresión ansiedad estrés discriminación
guerras inclusive suicidios
si el día de hoy les dieran la
oportunidad de resolver uno de estos dos
problemas cuales cogerían ustedes
yo creo que ambos problemas están
conectados y de hecho tienen la misma
respuesta la cual el día de hoy les
quiero compartir con mi teoría del
círculo biofísico
estamos desconectados desconectados de
la naturaleza desconectados de nuestra
comunidad
inclusive desconectados de nosotros
mismos hemos perdido ese sentido de la
vida enfocando mucho nuestro tiempo en
todas aquellas cosas materiales
posesiones y pertenencias y dejando a un
lado todas nuestras experiencias a
cuántas personas vemos sufrir con un
buen trabajo con una buena casa con una
buena familia cuántas personas mueren en
soledad
aún siendo millonarias cuántas personas
buscan el éxito pensando que eso es lo
que les dará le dará felicidad estamos
desconectados
vemos como personas están actuando sin
conciencia haciéndose tanto daño a ellas
mismas y a nuestro planeta pensando que
ese día de llegar de llevar nuestro
planeta a un punto sin retorno pudiera
nunca llegar cuando ese día pudiera ser
mañana y nunca faltan aquellas campañas
ambientales para ayudar todo nuestro
planeta que nada más se encargan de
difundir miedo y frustración nada más
nos preocupan diciéndonos que debemos de
renunciar a todas nuestras comodidades
diciéndonos que nosotros somos quienes
nos tenemos que sacrificar para salvar
salvar nuestro planeta y eso
evidentemente no está funcionando
por eso mismo me ha dado la tarea de
trabajar y pensar en una solución que
pudiéramos darle a todos estos problemas
socioambientales
desde hace muchos años he tenido la
oportunidad de trabajar con la
naturaleza convivir y también colaborar
con los huicholes los huicholes son
nuestras comunidades indígenas de la
sierra norte de jalisco que de hecho las
podemos encontrar en muchos lugares
desde durango nayarit tepic
monterrey inclusive en mercaditos ahí
los podemos ver pero realmente ellos
vienen de la sierra norte de jalisco
aquí en méxico siempre admirado esa
cultura colorida llena de vida su
conexión por la vida y por la naturaleza
como ellos se quieren como ellos se
cuidan y como ellos viven trabajan comen
rezan inclusive se curan con la
naturaleza ellos agarran las plantas
piedras fuego agua todo tipo de
elementos naturales para hacer sus
rituales y de esa manera ellos tener
esas experiencias también por otro lado
sentí una impotencia al ver cómo los
huicholes con tan increíbles artesanías
que hacen nadie las valoraba tanto y yo
por eso pensaba que vivían con tan
escasos recursos tiempo después me di
cuenta que la realidad
los huicholes son felices los huicholes
viven felices conectados entre ellos
mismos en su comunidad y en su
naturaleza y eso me llevó mucho a
investigar
bueno que es lo que ellos hacen que
nosotros no tenemos y cómo es que ellos
son más felices teniendo esas carencias
entre comillas de ahí sale la palabra
biophilia
la biofilia cualquiera que la escuche se
pudiera imaginar cosas muy feas pero la
realidad es que la biofilia es el amor a
la vida de hecho sus raíces etimológicas
vienen de vio vida y filia de amor lo
cual nos lleva a una palabra que alguna
frase que es el amor a la vida
lo cual nos lleva a una palabra que es
el amor a la vida por significado es el
deseo innato de conectar con la
naturaleza y de todo aquello que nos dé
vida de todo aquello que está vivo
existe un biólogo estadounidense llamado
edward wilson quien él nos habla de los
grandes beneficios de toda la biofilia
como el nosotros conectar con toda la
naturaleza podemos obtener muchos
beneficios a nivel cognitivo fisiológico
y psicológico por ejemplo si nosotros
vamos al bosque o vamos a la playa o
estamos en cualquier lugar rodeado de
elementos naturales eso nos va a hacer
sentir vivos eso nos va a dar bienestar
felicidad creatividad inspiración por
eso mismo que en todas las empresas hoy
en día están implementando eso
simplemente porque quieren más
productividad pero las raíces es que
aquella persona que está conectando con
su naturaleza realmente es aquella
persona que más felices pero que más
empática con su entorno
de esta manera entendí como aquellas
personas que conectan con la naturaleza
son las más felices pero también son las
que más cuidan de nuestro mundo
de esa manera estuve pensando
investigando y dije ok así es como los
huicholes son felices pero también por
otro lado logre entender poniéndome
empático con aquellas personas que están
destruyendo nuestro planeta con las que
aquellas personas que están
desconectadas y probablemente sean
infelices eso me hizo despertar más mi
curiosidad llegó una frase
y en una frase que me llamó mucho la
atención que es lo opuesto a la
depresión no es la felicidad sino la
falta de vitalidad
y pensando mucho en esta frase es ya lo
opuesto a la depresión no es la
felicidad yo pensé que la gente primera
era infeliz no simplemente no tienen
tanto amor a la vida por lo que conecte
las ideas y dije la biofilia que es amor
a la vida es vitalidad no solamente
pudiera hacernos más felices si no
pudiera probablemente combatir muchos
problemas de depresión
esto me llevo me llevo a investigar más
y encontré que la mayoría de las
personas incluyéndome buscamos la
felicidad en muchos bienes materiales en
objetivos como tener una buena casa un
buen carro un buen trabajo y eso la
realidad es que nada más nos hace más
materialistas porque entre más queremos
entre más tenemos más queremos y más
gastamos y más contaminamos y eso nos
hace unas personas no tanto de
experiencias sino de pertenencias ahora
habrá alguien quien me diga hoy jaime
ronda con la frase típica de hoy pero el
dinero claro que puede comprar la
felicidad bueno
en base a estudios científicos se ha
comprobado que la felicidad llega a ser
topa en cuanto hablando económicamente
en cuanto nosotros llevamos a cubrir
esas necesidades básicas a partir de que
nosotros cubrimos nuestras necesidades
básicas nuestra felicidad no está en el
dinero nuestra felicidad está en
experiencias está en conectar con
personas que queremos está en conectar
con la naturaleza está en servir a los
demás están a entregarnos a los demás
hacer ejercicio meditar a disfrutar de
todo aquello que nos dé vida
teniendo toda esta información dijo oye
qué interesante ya entendí cómo la
naturaleza y la felicidad de alguna
manera están interconectadas pero cómo
poner esto en práctica y al servicio de
los demás
y en ese momento
cuando menos me lo esperaba ahora sí que
el mundo me dijo a mí
jaime a ver si cambio físico vamos a
probar llegó mi prueba de fuego el año
pasado un empleado de mi empresa me
quemó todo el negocio prácticamente pude
ver cómo le ponía gasolina a todo mi
almacén quemando todas las evidencias
evidencias de lo que él me había estado
robando
ciertamente fue un momento muy difícil
al ver cómo en menos de 10 minutos me
había quemado todo siete años de mi
trabajo claro lo pude ver por las
camaritas no crean que estuve ahí
presente de alguna manera si fue difícil
pero pensándolo del al positivo dije
jaime es tu oportunidad para poner a
prueba y en práctica todo lo que has
aprendido todo lo que estás estudiando
todo lo que estás investigando prueba te
lo primero que pensé fue
recordar necesito conectar más con la
naturaleza y de ahí dos analogías que
nunca se van a olvidar la primera el
fuego la misma naturaleza nos enseña que
el fuego quema pero el fuego también
ilumina no hay fuego que no queme pero
no hay fuego que no ilumine y ahí
aprendí lo siguiente todos tenemos
nuestro propio fuego en nuestras vidas y
depende de nosotros si nos enfrentamos
ese fuego para quemarlos o para
iluminarnos
en mi caso mi negocio se quemó pero yo
no me quemé yo me ilumine frente a esas
llamas y esa manera puede encontrar más
respuestas en la naturaleza otra de
ellas una de las analogías que nunca
olvidaré es el árbol el árbol nos enseña
a que nunca podemos estar sin frondosos
nunca vamos a estar frondosas en todo
momento el árbol en temporadas podrá
tirar sus hojas secas y eso no significa
que el árbol esté triste
simplemente es un ciclo más innecesario
para que el árbol vuelva a retoñar con
frutos más grandes al igual nosotros al
igual nosotros vamos a vivir momentos
muy felices y momentos muy vivos muy
felices y muy difíciles pero en esos
momentos debemos de recordar que somos
naturaleza que somos como los árboles
los árboles lo que nos dicen es que en
toda temporada sus raíces se mantienen
al suelo sus raíces se mantienen a todo
aquello que les da vida que los mantiene
conectados y así nosotros de la misma
manera hay que mantenernos apegados a
todo aquello que nos dé vida en esos
momentos más difíciles
teniendo toda esta información expulsa
práctica lo primero
jaime yo mismo me decía yo sé que estás
preocupado jaime yo sé que estás muy
ansioso qué va a pasar con tu futuro
pero lo primero que debes hacer es
volver a conectar con todo aquello que
te da vida ahí pueden ver cómo empecé a
vivir más experiencias con mis amigos en
la naturaleza conectando más con mi
familia haciendo actores de caridad de
bondad abrazando a más personas y todo
eso no solamente me llevo me llevó a un
punto de felicidad empecé a fluir la
creatividad como nunca ideas proyectos
oportunidades me empezaron a caer y no
era porque yo mismo lo hice fue porque
la naturaleza me ayudó a hacerlo
teniendo todo esto concluir lo siguiente
el ser humano es increíble cómo funciona
de manera óptima siempre y cuando se
encuentre feliz y conectado a todo
aquello que le había
yo en ese momento sentía que había
descubierto la fórmula de la vida
increíble no
y de ahí sacó la teoría del círculo
bioquímico antes de pasar al círculo
bioquímico les quiero mostrar estas
imágenes estás imágenes representan la
secuencia de fibonacci fibonacci es un
matemático italiano quien descubrió como
todo en la naturaleza está conectado y
todo es perfecto mirando todos todos
aquellos patrones de la naturaleza nos
enseñan a que la naturaleza crece de la
misma manera en un espiral ascendente y
yo sabiendo que las personas somos la
única especie viva que hemos
desconectado con la vida
como me imaginé cómo sería nuestro
crecimiento de esa manera pero no por
nosotros en nuestra comunidad y en
nuestro planeta
y así fue como llegué a la teoría del
círculo biológico el círculo biofísico
nos muestra nuestro planeta en tres
capas en el centro estamos nosotros
estás tú en la segunda capa está nuestra
comunidad
y en la tercera capa está tu naturaleza
tu medio ambiente todos conectados por
un espiral ascendente ahora para aplicar
la teoría del círculo biofísico hay que
seguir tres pasos paso número uno
comienza contigo mismo
si se fijan estamos en el centro y todo
comienza contigo tú eras la semilla tú
eres el centro de un remolino tú eres el
comienzo de un gran cambio si recordamos
eso vamos a pensar cómo puedo ser más
biofísico hasta aquello que te gusta ve
y disfruta la vida eso te va a dar vida
y así vas a poder fluir y conectar con
tus demás capas segundo paso
recordar que somos naturaleza una frase
que me gusta mucho
creemos que la naturaleza depende de
nosotros cuando somos nosotros quienes
dependemos de ella de hecho somos
naturaleza
nosotros somos naturaleza y la
naturaleza que nos enseña que la
naturaleza viene para servir e inspirar
a los demás así que en todo lo que
hagamos en el centro haciendo todo
aquello que nos gusta haciendo todo
aquello que nos da vida recordar que
debemos de servir e inspirar a los demás
a nuestra capa de comunidad que es la
segunda ya nuestra capa del medio
ambiente que es cuidar nuestro planeta y
la tercera regla es si ya tenemos
conexión con nosotros mismos si ya
recordamos que somos naturaleza ahora es
el momento de poder conectar y recordar
que estamos conectados
en el momento que nosotros decimos estoy
conectado como podemos hacer esa función
si nosotros ayudamos al planeta ya
nuestra comunidad eso nos va a hacer
funcionar como el mismo espiral en
crecimiento natural pero si nosotros
hacemos algo que repercute en nuestra
comunidad oa nuestra naturaleza en el
mismo espiral eso no va desconectar y no
solamente vamos a dejar de funcionar de
manera óptima sino a nosotros a nuestros
vecinos
a la capa de la comunidad y al medio
ambiente también lo vamos a afectar y
que creen si afectamos al medio ambiente
eso recuerden que es un espiral entonces
se nos regresa verdad eso mismo a
nosotros nos afectan
teniendo esto en mente cumpliendo con
los tres pasos imagínense un mundo más
bien físico
imagínese un mundo en donde podemos
disfrutar más de nosotros mismos de
nuestra comunidad y en nuestra
naturaleza imagínense podría ser un
mundo donde juzguemos - y ayudemos más
un mundo en donde contaminemos menos y
reciclamos más un mundo en donde haya
menos peleas menos guerras y más
sonrisas un mundo en donde tendríamos
menos aviones y más pájaros menos
edificios y más montañas un mundo en
donde pudiéramos todos disfrutar más de
la vida como una familia más biofísica
pero esto comienza contigo si estás aquí
sonríe sonríe estás vivo bella abraza a
la persona que está a tu lado y
demuéstrale que la biofilia no es una
palabra es todo un estilo de vida
el mundo necesita ser inspirado a
reconectar con nuestras raíces si en
este momento entonces te estás
escuchando esta plática y no sabes cómo
ser más feliz no sientes como puedes
conectar más no sabes cómo inspirar a
los demás te recomiendo que vuelvas a
escuchar esta conferencia
que va a estar en youtube pero si en
este momento te sientes motivado a
conectar más contigo mismo hacer todo
aquello que más te gusta que más te dé
vida a servir a inspirar a los demás a
tu comunidad y a conectar con tu
naturaleza con lo que realmente por ella
estamos aquí ahora si te doy
oficialmente la bienvenida a un mundo
más bio físico porque esto depende de ti
ama la vida
[Aplausos]